another show that is definitely worth a
watch for a complete opposite reaction
is uh my final one which was uh
recommend a a dubbed hentai that's
actually good yes and uh man it was so
hard to just pick one if I'm there a lot
of good ones there's a lot a lot of them
are fantastic for for the wrong reasons
for the wrong reasons we're gonna we're
gonna end this on a good note yeah we
have one more after this yeah but like
you know I could have recommended like
you know classic going back to the
classics Bible black dub which is
[__] hilarious yeah but I I think
there's only one that it just just
crowns at the top and it's a little
series called sextra credit
and uh this dub is the ghost stories of
hentai like this this thing this dub is
absolutely incredible because of just
how self-aware the script writers were
yeah and just how bad the show is so I
guess the original premise is that
there's a teacher and originally the the
high school
um principal was an old man yep and he
left and was replaced with an all-female
student council uh a president whatever
yeah so to look over the school and he's
[__] pissed about this because they
don't like him and so I guess the
original plot because the the dub kind
of just changed the entire plot you've
seen the original plot uh I I I was so
confused by what I watched that I wanted
to find out what it was actually because
you could watching it you can tell yeah
oh this isn't what it's supposed to be
and so I went up I went and researched
what it was it was actually supposed to
be yeah yeah and I found out that
um because the original was so actually
disgusting it's so gross and it's so
despicable like it's it is nothing
redeeming about it and they try and
paint the main character as some kind of
hero yeah when all he's doing is um our
wording uh all this people and doing
horrific [__] yeah yeah and it's like
and so when they got to the dub they
were like [__] no we're not we're not
doing it like this we're gonna remake it
and make this guy a [__] loser and
make fun everyone's a piece of [__]
because this is just [__] this is
gross like and if we're gonna dub it we
may as well at least make it all [__]
stupid yeah Venus yeah
um and so for some reason he wants to
take revenge on all of them uh and so he
slowly does that one by one by
blackmailing all of them uh into doing
uh things with him yep and he slowly
gets more sadistic as The Show Goes On
yeah but in the dub it's not that at all
no um in fact it is some of the funniest
dialogue you'll ever see yeah so yeah so
you've probably seen and compilations
like YouTube clips and honestly just
watch that like I even watching the the
sex scenes in this did not there was one
or two more funny lines yeah yeah but
the whole show was so gross uh that I
just honestly the YouTube thing just
leave it at that that's funny yeah it's
it's and it's funny for the wrong
reasons like it's funny because he just
says stupid [__] and you can tell it's
obviously parodying the dumb [__] in the
show yeah yeah I mean the dialogue has
definitely uh not aged well let's just
say that okay let's just say I remember
the first scene uh where the first scene
is basically just this group of girls
like just
full-on like insulting this guy right
which is which I believe was yeah I
think not not what exactly happened in
the original yeah yeah I don't think so
but it's just it's just these four or
five girls insulting these guys
are the best way I can describe what
they say is just these girls learn
English from a Call of Duty Lobby okay
that's that's kind of what is said in
here my favorite one is you have less
spine than an earthworm you've left
spine than a spina bifida Victor yes
oh
yeah
I would say a lot a lot of language or a
lot of language used in this show has
definitely not age well yeah this show
came out in 2004 uh yeah it definitely
uses some like Newgrounds comments
section uh levels of language that
cannot fly today yeah it's it's a it's a
trip uh and not a good one
um even the dub is still just awful yeah
uh I I actually you know what I was
curious when I watched it I was like man
there's got to be some funny reviews of
this show yeah and to my credit there
was
um on Amazon
oh [__]
and there was some funny uh reviews if I
uh recall correctly why is it trying to
change my location oh yeah Amazon us
hold on let me go in our incognito tab
let me open up these reviews
[Music]
there was uh uh here we go here we go
here we go
um and the the headline of this is
properly describe your stock
two out of five stars my main problem
with this film that is improperly
described is listed you would think that
this is a variation of Harem style
however it is about as far from that as
possible this is a r slash Revenge
fantasy title and there was nothing to
indicate that if you were into that type
of story it works just fine however this
would be vastly improved if it was
indicated as such I would not buy it
again because I believe that the
customer should know what they are
getting especially in the field of
hentai and there's some other stuff you
know what valid valid my guy asked for
like tags yeah like I was like yo where
are the tags he was like it was like
where's the sauce yeah where's the sauce
for this someone also said four stars
sweetheart
what yeah another one said uh a decent
animation uh another one said exactly as
described five stars uh okay standard
review section okay okay someone said he
loved sexual credit on DVD and he want
more who is he this is a guy from the UK
as well I don't know who this is you
know if you start talking in third
person that's right
yeah but like I just I feel like this is
like whoever got there
whoever got their hands on a license for
this one has just lived my dream because
I've like this is what I wish I could
have done I wish I could because you
know 100 if you watch this some of the
lines that are said it is the script
writing how the scriptwriters having as
much fun as possible they are they do
not hold back uh with the jokes because
there isn't there ain't no if if you
actually jacked off to this I'd be more
impressed if you jacked off to this and
some of the other end times how are you
gonna stop yourself from laughing yeah
it's like trying to jack off to an Adam
Sandler film it's like it's impossible
like you can't do it you've just been
laughing the whole time there was there
was one scene where and also man with
these teachers weird oh yeah there's
this one scene where I guess the teacher
is just having orgies with all the
students yeah and then he films it and
then that's what he uses to get her to
do stuff with him yeah and then there's
another thing where
I just like he did I don't I don't know
what the vial is supposed to be in the
in the Japanese one yeah he whips out a
vial of red liquid and in the English
dub and he's gonna pour it on the girl's
area of uh of Interest let's say and in
the English dub he refers to it as
barbecue sauce with Tabasco
and I think it's supposed to be
something else in the Japanese one and I
don't dare go to watch it because I
actually don't want to find out what
it's supposed to yeah what if you go to
the Japanese one he's just like
and he goes I put extra [__] Tabasco
in this one and then he says a line that
a genuinely like broke me and he goes
there's so much barbecue sauce inside of
you what you ever certainly if you're in
a corn on the cob inside of you now it'd
be a complete barbecue or something like
that and it was just like what the [__]
is this dialogue
okay so you know what you watch you've
watched the uh sub of this right so this
I I know I watched the dub subtitles
okay okay uh so so you watch the uh raw
so I went to go and read the premise of
what it was and I watched two minutes
and I was like I'm done okay this is so
gross because because one thing that I I
was confused about by the plot of this
right is you know the first girl uh the
the first girl that he finds
um and uh and uh he I guess violates
yeah
um she ends up just like doing wanting
it 180 and just immediately joining him
yeah I didn't get that yeah yeah and
obviously the dub makes fun of this
right because it's [__] ridiculous
and why like in the dub they just goes
why did you sodomize me or something
like or something like that it's so bad
and then there's the scene of them like
sitting on the bed and and she's like
hearing all of his frustrations yeah
it says a line that just [__] killed
me he was just like wow you're really
understanding for someone who just got
all wood
like without knowing the story like yeah
I think even as like the dab alone is
still gross yeah this show is actually
so vile yeah yeah
um in general yeah that I think even if
just seeing the job it still doesn't do
it justice but then knowing the context
as to why they changed all the lines
yeah makes me just think did these dudes
are Giga chats oh they just saw this
terrible gross product and they were
like
I do not want to give I do not want to
appeal to this fantasy let's just let's
just [__] it up and let's just make fun
of all of this yeah I do not want anyone
to get bonuses no let's just make
everyone there's a reason why there's a
hilarious compilation of all of the
dunkers it's insane yeah out of context
it is so like what the [__] did he just
say there are there are like so many
there are so many like golden lines in
this I think another one the another one
was which is just like this is what
Andrew sees in his mind eyes it is
mine's eye which is I'm a man with a set
of balls and I demand to be treated with
respect yeah that made me laugh so
[__] much
it's probably one of the only ones I
genuinely recommend you watching if not
just for like the YouTube company don't
watch the set just just watch the just
use just watch the YouTube compilation I
think it's called This is the greatest
hentai dub of all time yeah the greatest
dub of all time yeah it's so the out of
context it's funny yeah uh but in
context It's just sad yeah it's a [__]
show that some someone just went you
know what I'm actually going to make
this somewhat enjoyable and you know
what I think they did a pretty pretty
okay they salvaged like a a car crash uh
going into a group of Orphans uh on a
plane that's crashing yeah yeah and then
at least we Salvage the steering wheel
yeah all right we managed to land the
plane yeah yeah